Останні хвилини очікування…
І Наталя Герасименко з Кривого Рогу не втримується.
Вона чекала повернення свого чоловіка два роки та десять місяців.
41-річний Микола Герасименко один з 73-х українських військових,
звільнених з полону бойовиків.
Він служив у батальйоні «Кривбас».
У лютому 2015-ого перевозив з іншими бійцями документи до Артемівська
і потрапив у полон. Те, що пережив там, волів би не згадувати.
Як зомбі ходив, під їхніми командами. Та й усе.
Виконував їхні команди.
Я їм там говорив, що на зло вам буду виживати просто,
щоб ви меніне робили.
Це весільне фото подружжя Герасименків 2014-ого року.
Тоді Миколу мобілізовали.
Про те, що чоловік у полоні, Наталя дізналася випадково.
Побачила в одному з репортажів його обличчя.
Наталя обійшла не один чиновницький кабінет, аби довідатися бодай щось про свого чоловіка.
Три місяці пішло на те, аби встановити, що Микола спершу
потрапив у полон до Російських козаків, а потім уже до проросійських сепаратистів.
Після цього Миколу внесли в офіційні списки на обмін, у першу десятку.
Наталя багато разів приїжджала до Києва напередодні анонсованих обмінів, але безуспішно.
Кажуть, що ці сепаратисти шантажують. Кажуть, що маніпулюють цими хлопцями,
що треба закон про амністію,
треба якихось виборів.
Це політика. Обмін полоненими став політичним процесом.
Цей перший і наймасштабніший обмін за останні півтора року
відбувся не лише завдяки кількамісячній роботі,
яку провели переговорники гуманітарної мінської групи.
Велику політику постійно підштовхували родичі полонених.
Мати Миколи, ризикуючи життям, разом з іншими жінками їздила до сепаратистів,
мітингувала в урядовому кварталі Києва, біля іноземних посольств.
Я думаю, що вже всім ми так набридли…
Вже не було терпіння ні в нас, ні в наших дітей…
27 грудня став щасливим днем не для всіх родин полонених.
Київ хотів обміняти 170 людей.
Але близько сотні українських полонених усе ще залишаються в руках сепаратистів.
Серед них - і шестеро військових, з якими відбував полон Микола Герасименко.
Він не заспокоїться, допоки його побратимів не звільнять.
Разом зі своєю дружиною хоче допомагати їхнім родинам
і намагатися пришвидшити вже анонсований другий етап обміну.